race
12 million heads up everybody knew how
to play poker actually around that table
except for one Daniel
he had no clue he sucked right I'm a
mess migelson and these are some of my
iconic characters some people tell me
[Music]
Casino Royale
weeping blood comes merely from an
arrangement of the tear duct of my dear
gentlemen
nothing sinister that was one of the
things that the director actually
insisted on because a real Bond villain
has something got golden teeth or an
extra nibble or something so so he went
for the eye thing Daniel Craig and iron
and Martin Campbell we had a lot of
ideas Daniel came straight from like
indie films smaller films and I also had
my background in The Pusher films we
discussed among other things that the
big torture scene and we went down
Rabbit Hole me and Daniel we had so many
ideas and it was getting crazier and
crazy and you could just see marching
going guys guys come back it's it's a
Bond film oh yeah you're right sorry but
he was quite open to to look and
experiment with the parameters of what
you can do in the platform I suppose our
friends Mr White would have told you
that I have provided reliable banking
services for many other Freedom Fighters
over the years
do you believe in God
I Believe In a reasonable rate of return
he's a he's a normal person he's not
taking over the world he's not one of
those guys he's any funny money and if
Bond didn't bump into his way they would
never have met it's not that he he's
after anyone so obviously he's
vulnerable there's people above him
people who are used to violence in a
different way than he is and it's a
different kind of villain that's for
sure
I played a lot of Poker since I was a
kid so so the game was not new to me the
hands we are playing are insane you know
so if you're a poker player you'll go
but we just wanted to make the the
nature of the betting uh believable but
the hands obviously had to be easily
recognizable for an audience that
doesn't play poker so they were quite
crazy hands but uh yeah everybody knew
how to play poker actually around that
table except for one Daniel he had no
clue he sucked and it was like it was
the worst thing ever that he of all
people had to beat me and win all my
money it was like this is wrong
well I got him back with the Rope so
that's good
[Music]
Doctor Strange
for well beyond time because time is
what enslaves this time it's an insult
death is an insult that was like some
Glam Rock from the 70s just coming up
there it looked good
took forever to be sitting three hours
in that chair every morning we cut it
down eventually but in the beginning it
was very elaborate I think we ended up
maybe an hour and 45 but it was still a
long time right and it was annoying uh
it was just annoying to be wearing that
but luckily I wasn't the only one you
can feel a little weird if you're the
only one doing it I had a whole gang of
resealots doing the same
[Music]
thank you
when you're in action film you do one or
two stunts and I I'm not the worst in
the world to do stunts I'm a former
gymnast and a dancer so I'm pretty good
at it so I get a little disappointed
like I did little in in the Bond film
when I realized the biggest star that
was doing in that film was to fold two
Aces it was like this is not right do
they know how good I am of this can I
get a chopper scene wet you know
somebody got fulfilled it in a with
flying Kung Fu and wise and stuff it was
it was really fun to be part of Bruce
Lee it's hot in my generation was very
hard not to be when you were like a
working class kid that was like that was
him you know him and Pastor Keith and
were unrelated though but I can see now
I I fell for both of them they have
something in common they have a certain
presence and and they have a
minimalistic way of doing things that
you know Buster Keaton could do very
little things and all of a sudden the
sky would just open right and so I've
always been fascinated by that without
putting my finger on wire and why I was
fascinating
the Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny and with this I will correct
them all you stole it then you stole it
everybody wanted their hands from the on
the breeding sciences that was working
for the Nazis and everybody was agreeing
that they should just shut their eyes
and not talk about it I'm a history
Buffet I know quite a bit about
that part I also know that there was not
only in the states that these things
happened it happened in obviously in the
Soviet Union to a degree in UK as well
so we did look at a lot of photos of
vanophen brown in particular and it was
interesting to see you know that it has
a certain dandiness around him he had a
little curve in his hair cool glasses
and he was just walking around you know
people and working with Americans as if
there was no past and that's shocking
but it's also it's also interesting to
see that with with what kind of an ease
that they just transformed from that
period to the next that we met my
memories
are you still a Nazi I think I remember
the most obviously working with these
fantastic people and working with Edward
Harrison of course is the top thing I
mean normally he would just see me
wherever I was randomly far away and he
would screamed that goes the Nazi right
okay thanks Harrison that would be like
an entire new crew who didn't know the
story and everybody thought it was a
Nazi great so that was his way of
warming up and I I liked it he's a
teenager he needs energy and everything
about him he's a legend for on some so
many levels right for his talent for the
stuff he's done but he's predominantly
in my world a legend because she doesn't
behave like a legend he just brings
everything down to earth and makes
everybody comfortable around him and so
we can make and create a scene Networks
Hannibal
before we begin you must all be warned
nothing here
is vegetarian Hannibal is a very
different animal he can be impulsive but
really it's a choice if he does it he's
in complete complete control he sees the
world differently than we do he's like a
fallen angel it just sees the opposite
he sees love where we see something
horrifying he sees Beauty when we see
something
very very ugly for him life is most
interesting and most fantastic when it's
on the threshold to death right in that
moment There's Something Beautiful
happening in his world so that's
obviously a Corey way of thinking but
I don't necessarily have to go down that
path I can just substitute with
something else that I find beautiful you
know something I I cherish and I think
that's the best way to approach it as to
as opposed to go down in a dark alley
then go down in a beautiful alley that's
what he's doing he's way too
intelligence for anyone I have no idea
how he learned all these languages and
how to cook play the cinnamon and shoot
bow and arrow to Perfection everything
it's like he's a lifter character right
now and for some reason he never got rid
of his funny accent he didn't have time
for that
[Music]
I did it at all yeah it's only doing
stuff flipping and catching an egg there
and so that's a lot of juggling in that
which I'm fairly good at myself there
was things that I didn't know why I did
in the beginning and then it makes sense
later like it's supposed to when he
sniffs wine like everybody else goes
like that he goes like just away from
him and then
I think it just needed to be interesting
to be honest it was just something
that's like that's weird he's doing that
let's just do it for fun and then he
realized it does make sense his nose is
so sensitive it has to be all the way
out here right
[Music]
did you just smell me difficult to avoid
so we didn't want him to be a classical
psychopath if that's the case then we're
gonna dive into his past what happened
to him oh there was something and it
becomes a banale story about oh that
could have been solved early on but we
kind of didn't like the idea of
understanding his path we just want him
to be this and not a classical
psychopath we want him to be a man with
emotions and with empathy but unlike the
other character the main character of
the show Will Graham who has no control
of his empathy he's just too much of
that Hannibal's complete control went to
him when to have it and when to give it
people they're like yin yang situation
right and that was the whole idea about
the show that they would circle around
it eventually something had to happen
and
since I did
[Music]
foreign
it was a frustrating read it was
immaculate it was beautiful but it was
also very frustrating to read it because
obviously I had this sensation of a man
who was just cornered from everywhere
and it was nothing he could hit there
was no one he could hit he couldn't do
anything and that's exactly what we set
out to do I think that's one of the
reasons why he's a very powerful film
so what's important for us that she felt
comfortable and so whatever we did
didn't rub off on her because somehow
she had to run around in that world a
little Innocent but also know just
enough what the film was about so I
spent a lot of time with her which was
fun and made me forget the situation
even though it's quite a heron
experience to watch the film they
shouldn't they shouldn't really have the
the knowledge of what we're doing in
that sense I've always found it like
um an interesting way for an actor to
forget himself in a scene we can start
overthinking stuff but if we just hang
in there with whatever the kid is doing
and just kind of Follow that energy we
tend to become better actors as well
Rogue one
if I took my own life it will only be a
matter of time before credit realized he
no longer needed me to complete the
project so I did the one thing nobody
expected I lied I made myself
indispensable and all the while I laid
the groundworker for my revenge
we call it the Death Star Arissa wasn't
evil he started out with good intentions
and then somebody took it away out in
Star Wars I created the Death Star
boom yeah I just did that and then
working with Felicity it was it was an
interesting because it was going back
and forth in time quite a bit and he
said goodbye to his daughter when she
was very little no knowledge of where
she went and she had no knowledge of who
he was or was she on the dark side or on
the good side so that was quite a
dilemma for them when they met up again
I've seen your message
it must be destroyed I know I know
we will
okay
[Music]
look at you it becomes very technical
when you do it for three days in a row
because there was so much involved with
rain and rain very hard to keep your
eyes open when the range was pouring out
so I mean obviously you just you look at
her and you you see over the first time
in 20 years and that's the same moment
where you have to say goodbye to her
again which is quite emotional and and
then before we get a chance you're gone
so you try to play the situation you
can't really plan for it and sometimes
it goes in One Direction sometimes in a
different but when you were with a
fantastic actress like Felicity it helps
a lot
another round
um
this is a film about the levels of
alcohol intake quite early decided
that's not gonna We're not gonna drink
on set because we do know what it is to
be drunk but we were curious about the
levels did we haven't correct or not
like 0.05 0.07 what happens so we did a
little boot camp where we tested out the
different levels and we acted out in one
specific scene and we've repeated that
again and again on different levels and
it was quite clear that after a certain
amount
that that was no communication with the
director anymore it was just for kids
talking and nobody listening
[Music]
[Applause]
and you get Freer and Freer and then a
little too free and then back again so
all these things were very important for
us to I mean we could obviously react it
and we guessed a lot of it but we also
it was nice to have had that boot camp
because there were there was things that
were super clear to us when we watched
it but when you were in the midst of it
that you had no awareness of like hands
all of a sudden they get their own life
let's say you have to fall for beers all
of a sudden they just have their own
life and you don't feel it
everybody told me that he was the
Godfather of that Universe he was trying
to pitch it to us more than once and
we're both like
I think I'm I think I got it but she
would just do the scene and you can take
over from there because there was so
many layers in it and when he was
explaining it Norman I just did our best
to not at the right place and say we got
it let's move on yeah I'm I'm not even
gone through 10 of it I have no idea how
to play that game like that again we've
dressed up in uh in a green bodysuit we
wear dots everywhere and we had wearing
a camera and luckily I wasn't the only
one there was more people like that so
would you do feel kind of ridiculous
running around doing that but his world
is so
so crazy everything was animated he had
a gigantic wall he's been doing all the
drawings of what he was going to look
like and it's just the world you have to
just trust him he says we did scenes but
they could also move a little and and
then he will always fix it later he
would always he's one of these directors
that was like just so grateful for
everything with it like even if we
bummed our heads together I was like can
we do it again and he was no it was
great we can fix it later and we kept
forgetting that it was animated thing
right
[Music]
push it
finally
Plastic Man says
she was telling me
the secret spot
s
man
you push a trial you use a film about
Copenhagen it's about beyond the belly
of Copenhagen which where I grew up and
the director did not want any actress in
his film he was one of these guys was
like everything was standing and I know
the producer said you fine
you've got to have at least two actors
in this one because it's going to be too
much of a handful for you you couldn't
find any uh and he kept casting he just
didn't like it the other world too much
theater in them and so and I was in
drama school and somebody said you could
take a look at this guy because nobody
understands what he's saying he's just
from that area of Copenhagen and he
mumbles he's fast and and he liked what
he saw so I got the job it was very rock
and roll and he deliberately asked us to
help give birth to this this film he
knew what the story was about he wanted
to capture it but he didn't know the
universe he didn't come from there at
all so that was cool for us so we were
two actors running around with a lot of
criminals shooting a film that was a on
a piece of paper that energy of making
films in that specific manner has always
kept with me you can't do it on every
single film that would be disaster to do
it with a Indiana Jones film but the
pureness and the cleanness of it uh I
think is is worth bringing to every film
if you can't in one dimension or another
so it's it's what I grew up with and I
will always cherish it I think it was
just a little rock and rolly and like
that would be fun that would be cool
let's put respect in the back of his
head and I don't think I was so super
aware that that respect was ironic in
the sense that there was no respect for
this character whatsoever it was a
tricky thing to go back to a character
that was so annoying I mean he was just
very annoying to be around also for me
it was a part of me that was like
we don't really want to do that you know
but then shave your head and you got the
tattoo and it's just like
I like him he's such an idiot let's go
[Music]
well hello rise
no I couldn't see anything it was not
see-through it's just a prosthetic and
it was super annoying for a lot of
reasons I mean we were in Scotland so
it's either was raining constantly or it
was just
baking Sunshine but when it was bacon
Sunshine they had all these bushes in
the in the mountains out full of little
animals called michies like little
biting kind of mosquitoes but with jaws
and it was billions of them sometimes
they they got caught inside my eye when
we when we did the prosthetic onset so I
would have like five or six little
animals trying to eat me inside the eye
and I was constantly going trying to
kill him yeah and there was a pain it
was a pain in the air he talks
who
one eye
what's he saying that was again one of
these things where it's like it's hot
because he was like in between a real
person or he was like kind of a myth we
realized really fast that little normal
things that people do scratch themselves
or or fast movement reacting to
something that he could we couldn't
really because we lost some something
interesting about character so we would
actually restart the first two days when
we realized that so we we went for more
for like and this is going to sound
pretentious because I never do this
normally but we did go for an animal
this time we did go for a like a big
gorilla in a cave that that doesn't move
like that it's just basically he knows
what's happening and when he moves his
head it is very slow and that that we
played around with a little but we took
away all the little fiddly things that
normal people do it's a strange film uh
it started like one thing on the on the
paper and and it changed a lot once we
came up there this is one of the things
that Nicholas also did to push your
films he can flip on a dime because like
I hate Vikings let's do something else
you know and that's what we did so we we
made a painting or piece of music within
the world of filmmaking
better have my money I was there
for two days I think that's the only
time I ever shot in in America all the
American films I've done have been shot
in Europe so thanks Rihanna thanks
Rihanna I finally got to shooting in
America yeah I don't know how it landed
I'm she must have seen I never asked her
she must have seen something I've done I
believe of something dangerous actually
she called my agent and it's like do you
want to be in a Rihanna film and I was
like yeah I'll respect Rihanna I'm I I'm
not picking in music so obviously I kind
of replace it and then I heard some
music oh yeah she's cool my son for the
first time I think was impressed with
what I do he wanted to to come with me
on set and it's like young teenager I
don't think so when she was so sweet and
then she's so good and it became a
really crazy video it didn't like the
the push of things in the sense that
there was a story I think we shot 10 of
that story because it went in all kind
of crazy directions all of a sudden so
it became more like
um an idea of this as opposed to a solid
clean story and so it was very visual
but yeah I'm pretty proud of being her
that's fine